you
let's try d4 b6 will go into a French
let's try that and let's go for a win
war alright we're not entering that so
it's gonna be much more open position
and black we'll end up having an
isolated deep on I think sitting on
chess cube after c5 this is the Marshall
variation okay II takes I take here I'm
helping black develop although I might
take here eventually maybe I'd want to
do it after the bishop has moved so
let's take here to start and I think
just develop Knight f3 not sure what I
want to do it my bishop probably Bishop
b5 in a quick castle I'm gonna go for
that Bishop check and castles rook e1
I keep the tension until this bishop
moves this pin is it going to be
annoying so much so that I should
prevent it with h3 this could be awkward
like Bishop here takes okay
well I'm still not gonna take here what
about this is that gonna be annoying to
pile up on that or what about Bishop g5
mmm right here I don't know how great an
inconvenience that would really be 95
Queen b6 initially that Queen c7 but
Bishop here you can always just play to
b6 though I don't see any anything great
about that what about just rook e1 or
bishop here
I want to play bishop here I don't know
how great it is to have this now I'm
really considering takes here or here
Bishop takes Bishop takes pawn takes I'm
really going pawn hunting doing it like
that
opponents flying what about
I don't know what I want to do a pawn
takes rook e1 Bishop takes Bishop takes
pawn here is that really being too
materialistic probably it probably is
I'm gonna take here when the bishop
recaptures then there's still this pin
to worry about and maybe in the meantime
I could post up on this d4 square maybe
right away actually if Bishop takes pawn
Knight d4 is available this knight still
pinned I'm hitting the bishop and nine
and if when my knight moves then I'm no
longer having to worry about maybe some
pin against by Knight with Bishop g4 so
if Bishop here I think I want to do this
Bishop in nighter hit Bishop takes Queen
takes they're still in a pin whoa that
must have been a mouse slip I think they
meant to throw a question to my bishop
they're not throwing out a take-back
immediately so okay I'm pretty sure I
can just hang on to this pawn now I'm
gonna do this ice I could play Knight a4
defends the pond but it's not strictly
defensive there might be Knight jumps
now since it weakened to b6 so a6 is
very suspicious this is more common to
just throw a question of the piece
that's putting you know that has you in
a pin and I'm just threatening to win
material taking twice on c6 Bishop here
starts to look kind of funny this is a
bit weakened
there are at least chewing on some time
now three-minute mark for them rook to
e1 useful move logical move open file
I'm not sure what candidate moves there
includes four black Bishop d7 Queen here
seems more natural and I don't know how
great a fan I would be of picking up the
bishop okay Queen there defends both of
these so maybe that was the idea if
takes the Queen's there to recapture but
the night is still dependent actually no
what now the queen is in a spot where
she can end up in a fork Knight B sixes
has a lot more appeal now so he's
definitely improved quite a bit and
he'll do so with tempo I imagine c3
versus b6 a very annoying piece he's
already annoying there's two pieces in
blacks position a third one ready to be
there a fourth one not long off they're
going in Reverse so strictly there to
defend b6 but I could take here I could
take the night and if Bishop takes then
I have this fork and if pawn takes
that's very ugly I'm gonna go with this
and now place the bishop in a pin my rip
belongs here less than two minutes
castles Queen side the Queen coming out
here rook up and over stuff very
appealing can't do it right away my
knight will have to do something came
there it seems like it's asking for
trouble with some fork rook takes Knight
takes stuff I think I just want to take
here I think the Knights are the better
pieces in this position I'm not gonna go
here just yet I think I need to activate
my queen if I could get my Queen this
age sex it's gonna be very annoying h6
King g8 rook III g3 bishop here I have
the check I can also think about
preventing Bishop g4 if I'm prevented
from getting to h6 with something like H
I could think about h3 flight square ok
I'm able to get there there really
should be something very soon here let's
start with the check this rook is
completely out of place either go here
or go back into a pin there's also this
knight move I'm gonna go with this now
that but now the bishop is pinned I'm
threatening night here
if the bishop defends this square he'll
end up being overloaded so I could play
Knight b6 with temp on the Queen there's
also a knight g6 stuff well the King's
running for the hills now maybe that was
best we hit the Queen she's short on
squares and then maybe just do what here
hmm my Knights gonna get tracked down
let me do this and then I want to get in
yeah I saw that you know I'm gonna do
this though I'm gonna give up my knight
there had to have been something better
I'm giving up my knight
but now I'm with this I'm focusing on c5
there's no maid on g2 so that's a check
I could pick up f6 probably should do
that soon I'm definitely gonna do it now
since it's a check this is gonna get
broken down now this is definitely gonna
be taken now definitely that's gonna be
at the queen is gone should be leading
to mate soon Hilda I'll be entering with
another piece King here I guess we check
and then get this one in with check it
should be leading to mate soon all right
they resigned
all right good game let's go back and
let me like I did before go into the
game history real quick and bring the
game up like this so it's a bigger board
suggestions out of this opening hmm
where did it I mean there might already
be well this this is just really weird I
think I think you have to recapture if
even if the intention was a six I think
I'm really in a spot to take the night
and hang on to this pawn with Knight a
four so whether or not this was a mouse
slip I think if a six was really a
intention I don't even think a six is
the right right idea a five definitely
is not but what should you do it
probably just picked the pawn back up
and then come back here to cope with the
pin yeah I think I think that's what you
need to do at this point I'm a again I
might really be ready to hang on to that
pond it really crumbles here fast when
you're having to run in Reverse do moves
like Queen to c8 stuff backing up at the
bishop the structure is damaged I mean
it's irreparable at this point so this
is really the main point and you have to
do something different here Bishop c5 I
believe is it
what's what's the downside with Bishop
c5 was there some fear of Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes and then Knight takes
here maybe but your queen is very active
on f6 I will need to invest the bishop
pair if I want to go pawn hunting and
you have a very active Bishop too like
Bishop takes c5 if I'm taking the night
queen recaptures Knight takes d5 I'm
hitting the queen I'm threatening a fork
Bishop takes Queen takes I'm on the
bishop yeah and then there's actually
rook e1 stuff so I wonder if there is
still some if that would be a good reply
would have if Bishop takes pawn Bishop
takes Knight is that in fact annoying
maybe so hmm
Bishop takes c5 Bishop takes Knight if
I'm even going with this I could go with
a more positional route trying to focus
on the the isolated pawn controlling the
square right in front of it on d4 92 d4
move the bishop Knight b-52d for
something to that effect Bishop takes
pawn however and Bishop takes Knight
Queen takes Knight if I go pawn hunting
Knight takes pawn I'm the queen and I'm
threatening a fork Bishop takes Queen
takes and now my queen will be hitting
the Bishop on c5 initially I thought
there might be the Queen coming down
here to pick up the pawn but in this
variation with these captures the
positions opening up and you're still
not castled so I wonder if we need to
even go a step back I wonder if
I wonder if this is something to
consider or actually at this point after
I Castle I'm stuck I'm actually quite
stuck here this is a I'm not sure the
exact move oh I know there there's got
to be something quite quite simple here
that you could be doing to not get into
too much trouble like this huh let's see
five takes takes
hmm
I doubt night here this can't be bad can
it really like Knight f6 give a check so
what locket I don't know how bad that
could be right
maybe Bishop here maybe there's an
improvement at this point what about
Bishop e7 right now Bishop e7 maybe
Bishop e7 is an idea too but I'm still
seeing I mean I've had trouble even on
the black side with this I've had
trouble with the Queen and the rook
bat-like forming a battery on the e-file
and I'm still not castled and kind of
stuck here but maybe this move is better
Bishop to e7 and if I capture maybe
maybe you could Castle maybe you could
still just recapture and if I give check
you come back this might be something
else to look into instead of deploying
the Queen Bishop the one who has many
more options than this guy with the
e-file being completely opened this is a
priority isn't it a top priority get
castled so I think moving your Bishop to
e7 is going to be the better decision as
you could hear it in my voice I'm not a
high percent on this but just throwing
out a suggestion at this move here I
think Bishop e7 focusing on castles is
gonna be better it does start to it it's
just too much to deal with structurally
structurally busted King position
material that sort of things so that
these are the main points before it gets
out of control right here the
development stage okay
good game pragma
you